this is
uh this is a good moment to bring up
something
i think a lot of what you talked about
is super interesting
and i think a lot of people listening to
this so now it's
uh anywhere from 300 to 600 000 people
for just a regular podcast i know a lot
of them will be very interested what
you're saying
and they're going to look you up they're
going to find your email
and they're going to write you a long
email about uh
some of the interesting things they've
found in any of your papers
how should people contact you what is
the best way
for that would you recommend your super
busy guy
you have a million things going on what
how should people communicate with you
thanks for bringing this up this is a
i'm
glad to get the opportunity to address
this
if someone's interested in participating
in a study
the best thing to do is go to the
website
of the study or of uh uh
like yeah which website so we have all
of our psilocybin studies so everything
we have is up in
on one website and then we link to the
different study
websites but hopkins psychedelic.org
so everything we do or if you don't
remember that just
you know go to your favorite search
engine look up johns hopkins
psychedelic and you're going to find one
of the first hits is going to be our
is this website and there's going to be
links to the smoking study and all of
our other studies if there's no link to
it there
we don't have a study on it now and if
you're interested in psychedelic
research
more broadly you can look up you know
like at another university that might be
closer to you and there's a handful of
them now
across the country and there's some in
europe that that um
have studies going on but you can at
least in the us you can look at
clinicaltrials.gov and look up the term
psilocybin and in fact optionally people
even in europe can register their trial
on there
so that's a good way to find studies but
for our research
rather than emailing me like a more
efficient way is to go straight and you
can do that first
the first phase of screening there's
some questions online
and then someone will get back in touch
with you um
but i do already start you know and i
i you know i expect it's like gonna
going to increase but i'm already at the
level where my simple
limited mind and limited capacity is
already i
i sometimes fail to get back to emails i
mean i'm trying to
respond to my colleagues my mentees all
these things my responsibilities and as
many of the people just inquiring about
i want to go to graduate school
i'm interested in this i had this i have
a daughter that took a psychoduck and
she's having trouble it's like
i i try to respond to those but
sometimes i just simply can't get to all
of it already
to be honest like from my perspective uh
it's been
quite heartbreaking because i basically
don't respond to
any emails anymore and
especially as you mentioned mentees and
so on like
outside of that circle it's
heartbreaking to me how many brilliant
people there are
thoughtful people like loving people and
they write long emails
that are really i by the way i do read
them
very often it's just that i don't the
response is then you're starting a
conversation
and there's the heartbreaking aspect is
you only have so many hours in the day
to have deep meaningful conversations
with human beings on this earth
and so you have to select who they are
and usually it's your family it's people
like you're directly working with
and even i guarantee you with this
conversation people will write
uh you long really thoughtful
uh emails like there'll be brilliant
people faculty from all over
phd students from all over and it's
heartbreaking because you can't really
get back to them but you're saying like
many of them if you do respond it's more
like here go to this website
if you're in for when you're interested
into the study it's
just it makes sense to directly go to
the site if there's
applications open just apply for the
study right right
right you know espec you know as a
either a volunteer or if we're looking
for
you know somebody um you know we're
going to be you know posting
um including on the hopkins university
like
website we're going to be posting if
we're looking for a position
i am right now actually looking through
and it's mainly been through email and
contacts but
should i say it because i think i'd
rather cast my network but i'm looking
for a postdoc
right now oh great um so i've mentored
postdocs for
i don't know like a dozen years or so
and more and more of their time is being
spent on
psychedelics so someone's free to
contact me that's more of a
that's sort of so close to home that's a
personal you know
that like emailing me about that but i i
come to appreciate more the the advice
that folks like tim ferriss have of like
i think it's him like
five sends emails you know like you know
a a subject that gets to the point that
tells you what it's about so that like
you break through the signal to the
noise
but i really appreciate what you're
saying because part of the equation for
me is like
i have a three-year-old and like my time
on the ground
on the floor playing blocks or cars with
him is part of that equation
and even if the day is ending and i know
some of those emails are slipping by and
i'll never get back to them and i
i have i'm struggling with it i'm
already and i get what you're saying is
i haven't seen anything
yet if with the type of exposure that
like your podcast
this will bring in exposure and then i
think in terms of post docs this is a
really good podcast in the sense that
there's a lot of
brilliant phd students out there that
are looking for posters from all over
from
mit probably from hopkins this is just
all over the place so this is
and i we have different preferences but
my preference would
also be to have like a form that they
could fill out for post
because you know it's very difficult
through email to tell
who's are really going to be a strong
collaborator for you
like a strong postdoc strong student
because you want a bunch of details but
at the same time you don't want
a million pages worth of email so you
want a little bit of application process
so usually you set up a form
that helps me indicate how passionate
the person is
how willing they are to do
hard work like i i often ask a question
people of what do you think it's more
important to work harder to work smart
and i use that those types of questions
to indicate who i would like to work
with um
because it's it's counter-intuitive but
uh anyway i'll leave
i'll leave that question unanswered
for people to figure out themselves but
maybe if you know my love for david
goggins you will understand
so anyway those are good thoughts about
the forms and everything
it's difficult and that's something that
evolves email email is such a
a messy thing this uh speaking of
baltimore
cal newport if you know who that is
um he wrote a book called deep work he's
a computer science professor and he's
currently working on a book about email
about all the ways that email's broken
so this is going to be a fascinating
read
you